hey 42 here if you switched on the news
recently you're probably familiar with
terms such as pandemic death rate social
distancing and lockdowns the world it
seems is on pause kovat 19 a novel
strain of coronavirus has revealed
itself to be the next disease pandemic
which will go down in the history books
right next to the Spanish flu in the
Black Death schools are being closed
hundreds of thousands of people are
losing their jobs shelves are empty and
so are the streets people are being
forced to stay indoors and most
personally people are dying the idea of
a global pandemic feels like something
reserved only for the distant past and
dystopian television but the truth is it
was always a case of when a virus was
going to consume the world again not if
the World Health Organization has been
warning the public of a global pandemic
for years naming the then-unknown virus
as disease X so if a pandemic was always
on the cards how have we stacked up with
kovat 19 well if we take the mortality
rate as a benchmark it could have been a
lot worse any loss of life is of course
deeply upsetting and one death is always
one death to many but when we compare
the statistics of this corona virus with
some of the previous pandemics as a
species we've come off lightly
the death rate of kovat 19 is currently
still at the beta tissue due to the fact
that we are still in the early days but
when we divide the number of deaths by
the number of confirmed cases worldwide
we end up with a figure of around 3.4
percent mortality but this figure
definitely isn't accurate in a
reassuring way due to insufficient
testing regimes almost everywhere except
Germany and South Korea the suspected
number of cases worldwide is thought to
be far greater than
cases which have currently been
confirmed which means that the mortality
rate is probably much much lower many
experts believe that it's more likely to
be around 1% of the UK's professor witty
reasoning that the mortality rate could
be as low as 0.6% obviously if you're
watching us in the future then please
travel back in time and give us a
heads-up but to put this into context
SARS another type of corona virus had a
mortality rate of 15% smallpox was as
high as 30% Ebola is around 50% and the
infamous pneumonic plague kills nearly
95% of people who catch it why am I
telling you this
well I don't mean to worry you but the
next pandemic yes I hate to break it to
you
there will almost certainly be another
one could very well mirror these
alarmingly high death rates and yet have
the same infectious variety of kovat 19
but there's good news covered 19 could
prove to be humanity's
saving grace and that it has come first
before something much much worse could
just prevent the extinction of the human
race yes you heard me right for years
now health has not been a top priority
for most countries sure we put varying
amounts of money into research for a
wide range of common ailments such as
cancer and heart disease but every
nation and NGO has been lacking when it
comes to improving prevention measures
and vaccines in 2018 the US
administration fired the team
responsible for coordinating responses
to pandemics and never replaced them
it's also reported that funding for the
CDC's global disease outbreak prevention
efforts was reduced by 80% are not
included their efforts in China awkward
so what changed now in early March
President Trump met with the leaders of
seven
major drug manufacturers such as Gilead
Sciences and Johnson & Johnson urging
those companies to work in close
collaboration with each other not
against in a race to produce a treatment
and vaccine as quickly as possible for
this virus asking Big Pharma to work
together is like asking the world
religions to unite and as a result of
this unprecedented move so far there
have been several promising developments
and there are at least 300 clinical
trials currently underway around the
world on possible life-saving treatments
for people who have contracted this
virus and vaccines to help halt the
spread
research into antiviral treatments and
vaccines has been given a fora kick of
the arse and in the quest for a
coronavirus treatment and vaccine our
understanding the viruses in general
will expand leading to potential new
discoveries and cures that otherwise we
might have never found if not for covert
19 which could possibly save us all in
the future there's also a good chance
that society's long-term approach
towards drug research will improve
dramatically because of the social and
economic fallout from covert 19 in the
future health will hopefully be
prioritized in a way that it has never
been before after all nothing inspires
progress more than money
and the markets have lost a lot of money
since the outbreak the footsy has seen
its biggest one-day decline since 1987
wiping 160 billion pounds from the
British economy and in America the S&P
and Dow Jones have been tanking just as
hard investment in disease prevention
could therefore be in for a major
incline to try and prevent another
disastrous economic blow in the future
unfortunately nothing motivates saving
lives more than the loss of wealth
because it is only those with wealth to
be lost that can enable research to take
place
but it's better late than never although
it is tragic that lives have to be lost
I view this outbreak as training wheels
for Humanity this pandemic has shown us
how woefully unprepared we were and the
sad truth is if we have implemented the
measures we are doing right now and
funded the research we are funding right
now ten years ago
tens of thousands of people who have
died so far probably would not have
nature has rolled its cruel dice and
luckily this time it landed on a one
whatever the fatality rate of kovat 19
turns out to be it will be in the low
single digits and that is due to nothing
more than look what if Nature had rolled
a four five or six this time what if
this outbreak had a fatality rate of 60
70 80 percent we wouldn't have the
luxury we have right now of this crucial
opportunity to fine-tune our procedures
develop our medicines and sharpen our
tools and minds for the future because
most of us would already be dead by now
covert 19 has given humanity that kick
up the ass it desperately needed and you
can be sure that in the future millions
of lives will be saved because of what
we're doing and developing right now in
the wake of this scary but mild pandemic
aside from investment in prevention
cures and vaccines since the outbreak
there have been significant steps
throughout the world to hinder killer
viruses from ever mutating and spreading
in the first place throughout history a
considerable amount of infectious
diseases have been due to cross-species
transmission this is when a virus
spreads rapidly after making the
evolutionary jump from animals to humans
pathogens that can do this are called
zoonotic
the HIV virus for example spreads to
humans from chimps in what is now the
Democratic Republic of Congo most likely
after being hunted and eaten by people
living in the surrounding villages a
swine flee made the jump from pigs to
humans in Mexico on a pig farm it
believes that covert 19 made the leap
from animals to humans in a market in
Wuhan China scientists are still
debating which animal passed it on but
it's thought to be either snakes bats or
pangolins but the surf fingers this was
just a ticking time bomb
China's wildlife market has always been
at the top of the list as the breeding
ground for the next pandemic why because
they are apparently bloody disgusting
literally they're pretty bloody these
markets known as wet markets are
essentially outdoor Abbott was selling a
mixture of live and dead exotic animals
with the live ones usually being killed
on the spot before being sold butchered
using the same knives and implements
used to kill other species at the market
carcasses are stacked on top of each
other their blood and diseases mixing
together in a potentially lethal
combination experts have long known that
this is a recipe for disaster
the w-h-o has repeatedly warned that the
next killer virus would come from wet
markets most likely in China but there
is a dim light at the end of the tunnel
in the wake of the corona virus epidemic
China has issued a strict ban on the
consultant and farming of wild animals
such as the markets in Wuhan where this
all began
China has finally acknowledged the
severe important to bringing this
dangerous industry under control in
order to prevent another deadly virus
mutation in the field
whether this ban is properly enacted
waits to be seen it's a profound shame
that it took the tragedy of many
thousands of lives being lost to inspire
this action but such measures could stop
a similar or worse virus in covert 90
coming in the following decades and with
China on board it's hopefully only a
matter of time before other countries
with similar food market practices
follow suit and if covert 19 a
relatively mild flu virus hadn't ravaged
the world this year we could have gone
on into 2021 still playing with fire
across Asia allowing the deadly
conditions to continue in which super
viruses mutate curva 19 may also improve
humanity on a more fundamental level
through the mass propagation of much
needed education on basic hygiene public
health experts have always stressed the
importance of washing hands and there's
a good reason for that keeping our hands
clean is one of the most important
measures we can take in avoiding
becoming unwell and crucially stopping
the spread of germs because most
diseases are spread by not washing hands
properly with soap and water for at
least 20 seconds sure you may be fitting
healthy but by simply washing your hands
you can save the life of an elderly or
vulnerable person don't be selfish but
surely most people already wash their
hands right well you might be shocked
and disgusted to hear that according to
a 2009 study cited by the CDC that 69%
of men don't wash their hands after
visiting public bathrooms and neither do
35 percent of women what all this might
be about to change a public health scare
such as this hasn't been seen in the
better part of a hundred years not even
our grandparents will have had hygiene
so prevalent at the front of their minds
as we do right now and this is having a
major impact on all our behavior
according to a YouGov poll conducted in
March 22
20 61% of people said they had improved
their personal hygiene this figure
although encouraging shows that there is
still a lot more to be done but it's a
good start if we're globally able to
maintain and improve this trend by
becoming more aware of how viruses are
spread we are in for a healthier better
prepared future it's somewhat deflating
that it has taken a global pandemic to
get people to wash their bacteria-ridden
hands but at least it's starting to
catch on it's only taken four thousand
eight hundred years since the invention
of soap but hey better late than never
so we've looked at how this latest
pandemic could prove to have a
life-saving silver lining in the future
but what about now surely covert 19 is
only leaving death and despair in its
tracks as it spreads throughout the
world at an alarming speed well what if
I told you that this corona virus has
already saved lives it's no secret that
air pollution in China is a significant
concern not only for the planet but for
the health of its citizens a 2015 study
from Berkeley of estimates that 1.6
million people in China die each year
from heart and lung problems and strokes
due to polluted air but in recent months
pollution has plummeted in China
specifically in nitrogen dioxide this is
a gas predominantly emitted by cars
trucks power plants and some industry as
China went into lockdown closing its
factories the air became cleaner but has
it saved lives in such a short amount of
time assistant professor at the
Department of Earth System science is
Stanford University Marshall Burke
thinks so
he conservatively calculates that the
reduction in pollution throughout
January and February 2020 has
potentially saved the lives of 4,000
children and 73,000 adults over 70 in
China by the end of this year China
could be in a position where more than a
thousand times more lives have been
saved by this coronavirus than it has
killed but it isn't just China
experiencing a positive environmental
impact Italy a country also feeling the
full force of this pandemic has seen
some unexpected but rather nice
consequences the canals in Venice once
murky are now running clear due to less
of boat traffic this has meant that fish
which were once invisible beneath the
cloudy waters are now visible and can be
seen swimming up and down once again on
the Italian coast dolphins have also
been spotted swimming by the ports of
Kali arey a sight not seen in years but
there's something else
spreading through the world right now
being passed from person to person
rippling through our communities an
unexpected coronavirus sidekick hovering
around the empty streets and packed
houses kindness with many of us having
to make drastic changes to our lives
we're all a little bit scared but
there's a growing sense of people caring
for one another the likes of which we
haven't seen since World War two apart
from the toilet roll orders yes I'm
looking at you random acts of kindness
aren't just trending across the internet
they are becoming a new way of life from
the teenager doing the weekly grocery
shop for his elderly neighbors to banks
offering mortgage holidays for the
poorest in society
only a couple of weeks after covert 19
hit the UK thousands of volunteer
community support groups have bootstrap
themselves from thin air offering
non-contact home deliveries and support
for the loneliest out there we may be
social distancing but we are becoming
closer than ever before may I leave you
with the inspirational words of the UK
Chancellor of the Exchequer Ritchie so
back when this is over and it will be
over we want to look back on this moment
and remember the many small acts of
kindness done by us and to us we want to
look back on this time and remember how
we fought first of others and acted with
decency we want to look back on this
time and remember how in the face of a
generation defining moment we undertook
a collective national effort and we
stood together it's on all of us stay
safe thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon it really helps
me to continue to make these videos -
links in the description also if you're
looking for something to keep you
occupied whilst in self-isolation
then you can go ahead and order my
brand-new book
stick if like in its a thousand years of
bizarre history from britain and beyond
the links in the description thank you